there seems to be some speculation that
a fifth wife
may be added into the mix what do you
guys have to say about that
yeah they've been talking about that
since basically season one
do you think there will be more children
in your future
you know what's the status of coyote
pass it was more work than we
anticipated
congratulations ladies 10 years of
sister wives
do you get nervous before a season is
about to come out yes
absolutely every time i'm like i do get
nervous i'm a little bit more
apprehensive to go out in public like
it's really
raw and open and we're super vulnerable
and she's super honest and sometimes
it's just not really fun to watch
yourself
a lot so i kind of cringe a little bit
when i think
that it's coming i don't know why i
sneer like this
my mouth goes up when i talk
it just drives me crazy there are some
of us who are like look i don't want it
anymore
yeah i'm sure everybody hates me all the
time i'm dealing with the stubbornest
people i've ever known
it feels like there's a lot of heavy
topics that we're about to dive into i
want to start by asking
what is everyone's relationship with
cody at
the moment like and what are your
relationships like with each other
cody and i've definitely had challenges
this year because we've had to spend
more time apart than we have ever
probably
so that's definitely been something i've
had to kind of
really think about and realize i still
like him and i still want him around so
that was kind of a nice
like you know we've been married almost
30 years so but i'm finding
with my sister wives i'm finding i value
that relationship more and more as the
years pass
cody and mary's relationship is really
sad
i can't i can't make him love me so if i
were to lean over and just kiss you
right now
would you push me away um no
i have been here from the beginning
since day one
it's really hard to look in the mirror
sometimes and be like huh what is it
that i need to change and improve on
so that i can move forward in this
relationship sometimes things
aren't better but sometimes but then
they always do get better
that's the thing that i find you know
you just work through it
and then you get to a point that's good
okay so should we take that as
a thumbs up that things between you and
cody are are going well at the moment
you guys are still together yeah we are
we've never heard romance and sex are
saved for people who are in love
if mary and i really wanted to be
together we would was there one
conversation for you mary that was
uh perhaps the most emotional or hardest
for you to get through
some conversations are really hard and
then you just kind of get through the
emotion
and figure it out and then just keep
going i don't want to give away any
spoilers
at all but i am here are there
plans to expand the family
do you think there will be more children
in your future our religious belief is
that we bring as many children to the
earth as possible and that is actually
um always a question and i'm not gonna
really talk about more than that other
than just that is always
like something that we consider and
wonder about and make sure and pray
about and make sure that we
our whole family is here with us i am
hoping that you ladies will
clear up a little bit of confusion there
seems to be some speculation that
a fifth wife may be added into the mix
what do you guys have to say about that
yeah they've been talking about that
since basically season one
now when you say they it's it's super
fans it's haters it's tabloids like the
bad
tabloids um it's just
that's what they've been talking about
for a long time but
i don't know about you ladies but i
don't see it happening because we've had
to be in four separate homes
and i'm very worried because it looks
like it's going to even be more
separation
i think now is the time for us to make a
plan on what we're going to do at coyote
pass
can i see a show of hands who likes
living
under one roof i mean i definitely
am for that i you know i don't think
it's a must but i always kind of thought
that was a great idea
but okay i'm i'm divided so if you're
going to ask on both
sides i think it would have been kind of
interesting to try i think it would be
fun
i'm definitely 50 50. because i have
done it
and i have not done it you know we're
not doing it right now
you know and there are definitely
uh perks to both the opposite end of the
spectrum than janelle
um i really like living separate i like
my own space
i like my own autonomy has it been
really frustrating to
not be spending as much time with cody
and by the way
how does the schedule work you know how
he spends his time has
always been flexible and adjustable so
generally
in a non-coveted year when there's no
concerns
he's pretty much just moving you know
every day or two
to a different house he just tries to
keep it pretty fair
what's the status of coyote pass still
happening
it's just going slower than we thought
but like
i know that we've talked about this big
dream and it being this kind of haven
for our kids to come
our grandkids to come i think about it
every night as i go to bed it's
happening
as your kids get older and you know
experience
relationships of their own what are the
conversations that you ladies are having
with your kids about
whether they should pursue monogamy or
if they should pursue a plural marriage
my kids aren't open to living plural
marriage in all honesty like they can't
we've talked a lot through the years
just about everything
and um none of my kids are going to live
our lifestyle i think that we can
acknowledge that they all love
the big family and their brothers and
sisters and the way that
you know and they really haven't
expressed any interest or whatever in
parole or marriage but they love their
family
just because we're doing it doesn't mean
that necessarily
it's for you so we were always pretty
open with that choice
just whatever makes them happy whatever
their path is is the most important
thing
like the four of us all chose this
and we would never take we would never
take that away from our children like
they need to find their own
path and their own belief and in order
to you know live their fullest life
does does that surprise you ladies that
you know they they've all seemingly
chosen the opposite of what they grew up
with
it doesn't surprise me at all because
it just proves to me and hopefully it
proves to everybody else that we don't
force our family to do
what we want them to do or what we think
they should do
you know that there unfortunately are
plural families who
are like this is what you're gonna do
and this is just what the kids grow up
doing
you know i've got siblings of my own
both
from my mom and from my other moms you
know
some have chosen it and some have not
i'm curious if your kids
watch sister wives are they allowed to
watch sister wives do you ever
uh feel protective over some of the
maybe like
more intense conversations that you're
having as adults in this plural marriage
is there ever moments that you're like i
really hope they don't see that always
in the back of my own mind i'm like
what if my kids see this i'm leaving
behind a legacy it's not just that our
family's on reality television
it's a legacy that we're leaving behind
and our children
see it and our children see the things
that we say
so everything that comes out of my mouth
is something that my kids can hear
and so that's puts another kind of like
makes you think
you know is this something that i really
want my kids to hear
and so even when you have to get super
vulnerable or when it's a hard
conversation i'm like you know what i
said some things that
i'm not proud of or i said some things
that were really difficult that are just
really more adult
and this is just with truly gwendolyn
isabelle are fine
um but i'm just like you know i'm gonna
leave it up to them and if it's
something that they are uncomfortable
with and a lot of times they're
uncomfortable a lot of times they're
like oh mom
why why did you do that you ladies have
been on the air
sharing very intimate personal details
of your life
with the world for 10 years how do you
think you'll know when the right time
to walk away is it's been really
amazing to make a difference in so many
in lives this year our friends finally
succeeded in
decriminalizing polygamy in utah that
was a
huge huge to me i was like a huge
milestone for why we did the show
so as long as we continue to do good i
hope we have a voice
i have no idea how i'll know i guess
when we get to that point i'll figure it
out or we'll all figure it out together
in addition to our plural family friends
we just have monogamists or
single people or whatever who always are
reaching out to me
who are saying thank you so much for
showing
a family just full of love robin is
there
a moment that maybe you're most proud of
over the last 10 years
i think excuse me
i'm the crier anyway um my my mom was
able to go
and be with my dad in the hospital
because
she's a plural wife and um she
walked in there and she said i'm i'm
from a plural family
i i'm his second wife i need to be able
to go
in there and be with him while he's very
very sick and that
and they just went okay and it was
because they knew our show
and because there's so many people out
there that are getting likes
a different view of what a plural family
is because of
because of our show that my mom was able
to go in and be with my dad
so it's a big deal to me my last
question to you ladies
so many misconceptions what is the
message or the big
takeaway that you hope uh viewers who
are tuning in to sister wives that they
take away
i think the biggest thing for me is that
that people understand that we chose
this
we're not broken um that
you know our biggest and most important
thing is the love in our family and
even though we have issues in our family
we are always
working towards working it out and
becoming stronger as a family however
that looks
[Music]
you